when we look at the last I don't know
two years one of the things that sticks
out around the central bank is that the
Federal Reserve is holding interest
rates artificially low at zero percent
uh and they also were conducting
quantitative easing even though
inflation in the summer of 2021 got over
five percent and by the end of the year
was over seven percent what is the
importance of realizing in hindsight
that that probably was a mistake is it
something that you can kind of ascribe a
a level of uh severity in terms of the
problem we're experiencing now uh or how
do you kind of analyze that action like
that's such a crazy thing in hindsight
that they were still doing that how do
you look at it
one of the the challenges I find is
determining what is a mistake and what
is intentional right so if they know
that there's super high debt levels and
the only way to discharge them is
through inflation
um you could make an argument that it
wasn't a mistake
um whereas this is kind of like are they
smart but then being misleading or are
they actually dumb right so it's kind of
like one or the other
um there was a BlackRock paper written
in 2019 before the the pandemic and it
was like you know the next downturn
monetary policy is not going to be
enough because Industries are so low and
debts are so high so we're gonna have to
do significant fiscal stimulus but that
can be inflationary and drive rates up
so they're going to have to keep rates
low through monetary policy so you're
gonna have to have coordination between
fiscal monetary policy but then the
challenges that can cause runaway
inflation so that's going to be managed
very carefully so they actually kind of
laid out the whole Playbook ahead of
time and and that was both BlackRock and
it was it was advised by Stanley Fisher
former former fed official and of course
they didn't predict a pandemic but so
it's it's kind of even bigger than than
that paper would have suggested but we
actually followed that Playbook almost
step by step in terms of watching what
these policymakers are doing
um and so you know I think that they
they over they certainly over did I
think even in their view I think that
part I think part of the original one
they wanted to let it run hot for my
first reason that they they wanted to
burn some debt away but I didn't think
that they did they thought it would get
this hot this quickly
um and I think if they did they probably
would have done certain things
differently and I think it's because a
lot of their models are just not not
great I don't I don't think they're
looking at at oil capex the real world
supply side stuff and I also don't think
they're making a great distinction
between broad money supply and base
money supply as its impact on inflation
I just think that a lot of their models
are out of date and that the models are
kind of bureaucratic I mean they're
they're these large institutions a lot
of academic input
um and I don't I don't think they have
like the the rapid learning effect that
you see more in like the business world
when we think about this inflation I
want to talk about two specific uh
contributions uh so we're talking about
the data and how they didn't think that
inflation will get this hot this quickly
the first one is what I'll call kind of
external events so obviously the
pandemic is one that you mentioned
there's also been uh supply chain
disruptions that have kind of come in
the wake of that there's been
geopolitical conflict with Russia's
invasion of Ukraine how do you
anticipate them uh either trying to uh
see these events coming to analyze them
in real time like how much of an impact
do these external events have on
changing their policy or is it something
where they just have their policy
they're going to execute their plan and
although these things happen they don't
really either pay attention or they end
up not actually being willing to change
the plan uh regardless of what happens
externally
I think these external things eventually
change their plan especially as
expressed through markets um and so the
FED has to kind of put out fires as they
come uh and so these events kind of you
know end up showing up in markets which
then ended up having to be the things
that the FedEx respond to so for example
they you know in in 2019 I bet none of
them expected what they'd be doing in
2020 at the scale they were doing it at
and so they had to you know I mean they
had an emergency meeting in March 2020
and they were kind of changing their
plan because the treasury market broke
which I don't think was on like you know
their 2019 Bingo cards
um think you know things like what we're
seeing geopolitically it's challenging
because
it's like it becomes self-referential
usually
um you know the the problems like when
you have long-term debt Cycles blowing
up and then you have more inflationary
periods that leads to more discontent
and more geopolitical struggle which
then leads to more inflation and and so
it's kind of that vicious cycle uh
that's generally what you see in these
periods and so one leads to the other
one leads back to itself
um and you know when it comes to for
example what we're seeing in in say you
know Ukraine Europe's Energy prices so
natural gas prices in Europe which which
if anyone has looked at them they look
like a Weimar chart it's like it's a
horrifying price chart you know compared
to what we're what we're experiencing in
the United States in terms of energy
prices so no natural gas prices soared
but that happened in late 2021 they were
already encountering challenges with
that and then you know the whole Russian
invasion just added more problems on top
of that it didn't create the problem
initially it just added layers of
additional risks and insecurity and
additional volatility and inflation on
top of what was already you know a
physical constraint in terms of natural
gas and other things that happening
there and so I think that's going to be
the theme of the 2020s is basically
problems feeding back on on making the
problems even worse